then I went from Beirut to Jerusalem in
one day literally drove in a car taxi
several taxis but you could make the
trip in six hours really if you could
drive directly and I stayed in Jerusalem
from June of 1984 until the summer of
1988 it was the best part of living over
in that part of the world well I think
the best part of living in Beirut was
the fact that you are living in the
world's biggest Skinner box you're
living in this environment this kind of
super heated atmosphere where you really
got to see how molecules behave when the
temperatures really turned up you learn
more really about human beings and about
yourself in a place like Beirut then in
my case I did in the previous 30-some
years of my life you get to see what
what people are made of how evil they
can be and how good and generous they
can be because in Beirut everything was
writ large everything was at the extreme
edge let me ask you a naive question
from watching the news I conclude when I
see Beirut why would anybody state it
it's a question I get from many people
Brian and there's no one single answer I
think the first and most common
explanation today is that everyone stays
for a reason somebody's a most of them
are prisoners of their assets that is
people have built houses businesses or
careers around their lives in Beirut and
as shattered as those careers or homes
or businesses maybe they just don't want
to leave and start over somewhere else
it's a very human thing so no matter how
bad the situation gets and no matter how
shatter those businesses lives and
careers become they always hope that the
next ceasefire the next lull in the
fighting will bring that fundamental
change that will make everything right
again other people are staying because
they've got a relative an agent
grandfather or an aged father mother
who's simply too sick or too unwilling
to pick up and start over some
where else and for others well it may be
crazy and it may be dangerous and it may
be surreal but it's home how many people
live there in Beirut over a million did
live there how many live there today is
anybody's guess when was the last time
you're in Beirut nah I was not in Beirut
since 1984 is it or was there when you
were there any part of Beirut that was
perfectly normal
well and know where that was really
perfectly normal yet normalcy could
still characterize a great deal of
Beirut life
what makes Beirut such a wild and crazy
and absurd place to live is not that
people get killed it's that they get
killed playing tennis or they got killed
taking their kids to school they got
killed playing golf that's why I called
the second chapter of my book would you
like to eat now or wait for the
ceasefire which is a quote from a dinner
party in Beirut and reflect excuse me
reflects the kind of absurd
juxtaposition of life there where life
was always secure enough for you to go
about your day but never secure enough
for you to be sure that that day
wouldn't be your last so my wife and I
were members in good standing of the
Beirut Golf and Country Club when we
were there and when they talk about the
first hole there is a dangerous par-5
let me tell you they aren't just
whistling Dixie
all right the PLO had a shooting range
which faced the driving range of that
golf course it was the only golf course
where I was happy to go into a sand
bunker it's like the safest place you
could possibly be but people played and
there was a man I used to play with
George Beaver who I write about in the
book who played every day of the
Lebanese civil war by himself he'd only
take out a few clubs some days he'd play
the holes forward some days he'd play
them backwards he was an Englishman who
had retired to Beirut he gave a whole
new meaning to the term only mad dogs
and Englishmen would play on a day like
today well I once asked George I said
George we're out playing this is crazy
and he said yeah it's crazy that we play
but we'd be even crazier if we didn't
play and that's really the lesson of
Beirut the way you survive in a place
like Beirut is not by hiding in a dark
corner of your of your cellar that's how
you go crazy
the way you survive is by getting out
and trying to lead as normal a life as
you possibly can from what I've seen
you've done very well on your reviews
have you gotten any bad reviews I've
gotten a few extremely negative reviews
mostly from American Jews or entirely
from American Jews who are I would say a
more right-wing persuasion who were
upset by the fact that I criticized
Israel in the book criticizes Israel I
think in a very sympathetic way but
nevertheless they simply couldn't
countenance any kind of criticism of
Israel but I don't take these reviews
seriously the book has been warmly
embraced I think in the majority of the
American Jewish community Israeli
publishers competed for the right to
publish it and Hebrew there's going to
be a Hebrew edition of the book it's
gonna be excerpted in the Israeli
newspaper Maariv
and it's gotten they broad and and I
think sympathetic a response from from
Jews from non-jewish Americans and from
Arabs as well when did you start writing
I started writing the book in January of
1988 and I finished it in February of
1989 took me about thirteen months first
book first first book I wrote an essay
for a book of photographs about Lebanon
but it was just a short essay this is my
first real book why did you write it why
did I write it well I I guess because I
mean in the simplest sense I just had
more to say after 10 years in the Middle
East it wasn't that the times that
somehow not allowed me to say what I
wanted there is a reporter to the
contrary it allowed me to to say it for
10 years the the thing was so I really
wanted to sit back and reflect on all I
had said to try to sum it up to try to
see the patterns to try to set a
framework really for myself to
understand this period of 10 years that
I saw in the Middle East in Ho
said that framework would serve for
others to understand the middle-east
both tomorrow and yesterday and that's
what I try to do in every chapter is
really lay down a framework that if you
you read this chapter of this book
you'll be able to understand the Middle
East today this was so many of the
reviewers have said so many people have
called me or written me said you know
for the first time I understand this
place the books been on the New York
Times bestseller list for six weeks and
for a serious it's number five as a
matter of fact the this Sunday for a
serious non-fiction book on the subject
like the Middle East which most people
say the Middle East please
okay do me a favor but I don't want to
hear about the Middle East I think it's
a it's for me it's the best compliment
that I've managed to present you know
this part of the world in a way that's
both comprehensible and if I do say so
also funny and humorous sad and tragic
as well but I think I capture all the
emotions of the area for our viewers
this is being recorded in late August in
case they say hey I've seen it up there
and it's now number one in the New York
Times basically yeah number five on
Sunday the 27th what does it mean to be
Jewish what does it mean to be Jewish
Jewish in the Middle East or the Jewish
when you thought about that much it's so
comes up so often on this network
callers calling it both Jews and
non-jews the whole discussion about it
what does it mean to you well for me
it's I think it means being part of a
particular community with certain shared
values which you know go by the name of
Jewish values but judeo-christian values
in some ways now we think of many of
them but for me it's more of a communal
a sense of tribal almost identification
not something that is for me personally
a religious in the sense of going to
church or synagogue kind of experience
why is your family religious wasn't
religious I would say it was a typical
American I'm from Minneapolis Midwestern
Jewish family uh we went to synagogue on
the High Holidays of
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur but it
wasn't an orthodox family by anything of
that nature did you run into prejudice
about being Jewish in Minneapolis Oh
certainly when I grew up there was
anti-semitism in Minneapolis my family
couldn't join triple-a for instance in
the 50s because of anti-semitism but I
think that's something that's long
passed what does it mean to be an
anti-semite means certainly not to
someone who hates Jews as far as I far
as I know and do you have any idea where
what the origin of all this is where
does this kind of thing start it's
probably really beyond my my capacities
as a journalist or an authors to get
into that really it's it's a little
beyond me
beyond probably the confines of my book
as well does it does it affect your work
wherever you go well certainly my
identity does and being a Jew in the
Middle East which is something I talked
about in the book quite a bit um you're
certainly affected how I perceived the
story how I saw the story being a Jew
covering the Arab world which is
something I discuss in detail was an
interesting experience and also being a
Jew the first New York Times
correspondent who was Jewish sent to
cover both the Arab world and Israel
brought with it a lot of challenges and
I think a lot of opportunities if you
were in a position of an editor at the
New York Times would you do to someone
else who's Jewish what they did to you
well I don't think they did something to
me I think they did something for me
yeah would you do it again yeah
definitely definitely Abe Rosenthal who
was then the editor of The Times really
thought it would be interesting to see
how I would report the Arab world being
Jewish and although having studied
gotten a BA and graduate degree from
Oxford in Middle East Studies so he knew
I had a background in the Middle East
how I would cover the Arab world and he
thought it would be equally interesting
for our readers in the paper to see how
I would filter Israeli society and I
think considering that I want to feel
surprise for my coverage of Beirut and
pure surprise for my coverage of
Jerusalem he was happy with
experience as were a lot of our readers
when you approach this book what are the
things the techniques that you used to
keep people interested well it's a good
and to get on the bestseller a good a
good question by the way I approached
the best piece of advice I got before I
wrote this book was from a colleague of
mine David Ignatius who is the editor of
the outlook section at the Washington
Post and himself has written a novel
about the Middle East a very good novel
and he said when you're writing this
book always imagine whether the reader
is gonna want to turn the page whether
you know what you're writing how you're
writing the anecdotes you're selling
you're telling will compel that reader
to want to turn the page and that's what
I tried to keep in mind
hence the book is a really a combination
of analysis of history of autobiography
of anecdote all kind of put in my own
kind of Cuisinart and comes out the
other end in a way that I think really
many people have said you know reads
like a novel much more than any kind of
nonfiction book where did you write it I
wrote half of it in Jerusalem and are
spent half the time of my year off to
write the book in Jerusalem writing the
book there in our department we lived in
there and I spent the rest of the time
at the Woodrow Wilson Center here in
Washington DC at the Smithsonian
Institution finishing the book in your
back full time now I'm back full time
I'm the chief diplomatic correspondent
for the New York Times covering
Secretary of State Baker let me show the
audience this map which is one of the
few graphics in the book and use many
pictures no we didn't we didn't use any
pictures it's basically just maps and my
own story this is Israel right all right
and you focus here on Jerusalem I don't
know if we can get a real tight shot of
this but how did you try to explain to
us what is Jerusalem
well Jerusalem of course is a capital of
Israel it's a city that is holy to
Christians Muslims and Jews
and it is in many ways you know the
centerpiece of this conflict why because
everyone wants to control the city they
believe as closest to God and what's the
origin of that I know this these are
some posted questions well if you aren't
thinking uh-huh
beyond just the Daily News why is this
such a sensitive place well precisely
because so many people have attachments
to it really in many ways see it as
God's throne on earth whether they be
Christians Muslims or Jews and everyone
wants to be buried there why you know if
the Messiah is gonna come whether again
the Christian Muslim or Jew you want to
be buried in Jerusalem so you'll be the
first to be resurrected so everyone has
I think their own spiritual connection
to this place which makes it so
compelling and so much a source of both
of friction and and delight was it
strange to you if I if I read you right
you're not very religious is it strange
to you to live in a community that
everybody running around it's very
religious or are they um well Jerusalem
of course does have a very religious
flavor to it and again you see many
religious Jews in the city you see many
religious Muslims you see many religious
Christians I was more fascinated by it
then alienated or repelled or put off by
it I I found it part of what I liked
about the place part of its kind of
intellectual energy that you had all
these currents swirling around each
other and I found it fascinating how big
is the city Jerusalem is an overgrown
village really it's um it's a city that
occupies this enormous space in our
imagination but in the real world is
really very small and charming how many
people live there Oh probably about half
a million something like it how is it
divided we'll it's divided into
basically predominantly Arab eastern
half of the city East Jerusalem which
includes also the old city of Jerusalem
where the holiest Muslim Christian and
Jewish sites are located and there's a
new
or western half of the city almost
entirely Jewish half where you have
basically modern Jerusalem where do the
Christians live they live primarily in
the Eastern Arab half of the city and if
you were to travel there and which a lot
of people do can you tell the difference
between East and West physically well
today I would say they've been largely
melded together but certainly not
entirely of course the Arab half of the
city you have shops where you have
science in Arabic all over the place
you'll see more people in Arabic dress
on the streets and certainly the old
city which is surrounded by a 16th
century Turkish walls looks like almost
a Walt Disney like fortress is something
that nobody can miss or mistake for the
modern half of the city and the people
that live there are citizens of what
country the people who live there in the
Arab eastern half of Jerusalem are
according to Israeli law have been
annexed by Israel and have the right if
they want to to take out Israeli
citizenship all of those people also to
this day still bear Jordanian citizens
citizenship Jordanian passport so you'd
have to ask them really to get a
definitive answer to your question how
many Christians are there I don't know
really the figures up right maybe
they're roughly maybe in Jerusalem a
quarter of the Arab population can a
Christian be an Israeli member of the
Israeli state yes there are many
Christian Arabs who are residents and
citizens of the state of Israel you have
towns like Nazareth for instance in the
Galilee where Jesus was raised which is
a predominantly Arab town that is
entirely Christian or made up of almost
entirely Christian Arabs so same rights
is all Israeli citizen certainly in
theory obviously in practice that does
not always apply is the first to tell
you but in theory there certainly
Israeli citizens if we had around the
table here
this is there's no such thing I suspect
is an average Christian an average Jew
an average Muslim what would you say
about each one of those people that made
them different from one another I
wouldn't want to step into any kind of
characterizations like that are they
different I think that to the extent
that they see the world through a
religious lens clearly each you know has
a very different religious
interpretation of both yesterday today
and tomorrow
but as as people who you work with in an
office or you know take a trip with I
I'd be hard-pressed to point to any real
distinguishing characteristics from what
you know the people who live in
Jerusalem today do they get along they
get along to the extent that they have
to get along but I think that there's
still a good deal of tension everyone
kind of lives within his own world in
his own community do you think after
your experience over there and obviously
thought a lot about that this problem
and I don't know what this problem is
that the Middle Eastern problem will
ever be taken care of well ever resolved
I don't think it'll ever be resolved
perfectly and finally simply because
there are too many conflicting claims I
think it is possible to resolve it in a
way that might satisfy the majority of
Palestinians and the majority of
Israelis in the majority of surrounding
Arab states but I don't see the
prospects as very high for a piece of
varisai like peace where everyone would
one day sign with gold and pen and
parchment a final and conclusive peace
treaty to the Middle East it hasn't
happened in 3,000 years so I don't see
why just because little Tommy Friedman
from Minneapolis comes out to the area
and says everyone should make nice that
is gonna happen today you meet many
people in the Middle East it felt that
it could be solved the problems oh
everyone believes it could be solved and
everyone wants it to be solved but
everyone wants their own kind of peace
you know everyone if you asked him to
say oh of course I want peace I'm all
for peace but then you ask them what
kind of peace
is it a piece the other guy can live
with that's another question if you were
to go back right now to the Middle East
and you had to pick one person in the
entire area
uh-huh you personally would want to go
see who would that person be I don't
think I could point to a particular
person I would say there are several
people who I never got to meet as a
reporter who I'd love to sit down and
have a good long talk with certainly one
is Menachem Bagan never never never got
to meet him he had gone into seclusion
by the time I came to Israel as a
reporter and I would love to have a good
long talk with Menachem Bagan Hafez
Assad as president of Syria it's another
man
I wouldn't mind in fact I would enjoy
having a good long talk with he refused
to talk to you uh never just had the
opportunity I can't say that I you know
I was in Syria but it wasn't like I
apply it and he refused to talk it just
for whatever reason the opportunity
never arose anybody else anybody else um
I wouldn't mind sitting down for a long
and heart-to-heart chat with Yasser
Arafat as well never did that um I had
many interviews with our fought but
those are all within certain confines
about certain news events at a certain
time I'd love to sit down and really
have a good good chat with him let me
ask my question because I didn't I
really wasn't looking for personalities
as much as the person that you would
call that you met that may be written
about in your book that you would find
the most interesting you'd love to go
back to see again uh why I know under
new people yeah it's it's really hard
for me Brian to name anyone I there are
hundreds maybe thousands of voices in
this book and many people who I I came
to enjoy on this journey and the book is
about a journey really and the people I
met along the way and one of the things
I've enjoyed about the book coming out
his old friends from Beirut calling me I
was talking to
diplomat this morning you told me that
an old friend of mine a figure in the
books Absalom who used to be the
Lebanese Prime Minister he was very
close friend of mine in Beirut he said
it just had a serious heart attack and a
Los Angeles and was recovering and was
in the intensive care ward and my friend
went out to see him and he had my book
by his bed and he had already read 125
pages in intensive care and he wanted to
argue with my friend about the book as a
matter of fact and the doctors
immediately came in and you know it took
my friend out he said he's in no
condition to be doing that I got an
enormous kick out of that and I've heard
from a lot of people a lot of old
friends and that's given me a lot of
satisfaction
do you have other stories similar to
that word or a story of someone who has
read this book and you put the phone
down he said that's why I wrote the book
oh definitely just before I came over
here a woman called me she sounded like
she was Indian Indian from India not a
Native American and but an Indian
American I would say and she said I I
just have to tell you I bought your book
last night
and I stayed up all night to read it you
don't know me I'm not Jewish and I just
want to tell you how much I enjoyed the
book I read you know that you report for
the New York Times from the Washington
bureau so if she looked up the bureau
and the phone number phone book and
called me up and that's who I wrote the
book for I didn't write the book for
experts I didn't write the book for the
officials out there for prime ministers
and cabinet ministers I wrote the book
for the average American who's been
watching this story for the last 10
years or 20 years hasn't been able to
figure it out for hiding her hair and
wants a way to understand it and that's
who I wrote it for and that's who I
think is buying it and that's what gives
me enormous satisfaction from what you
know any of the leaders over there I
read this book I got a call from the PLO
office here the other day saying they
had received a fax from chairman Yasser
Arafat that he wanted to read the book
and they asked me if I would bring a
copy over
form which I did do you sense and they
had a lot of years over there the New
York Times that the media plays a big
role and if it is if it does how big a
role is it well it plays a very
important role I have two chapters in
the book about that one chapter is about
reporting from Beirut called Beirut city
of versions which is a quote from a
colleague of mine of the late bill
Farrell who once remarked that there's
no truth in Beirut there's only versions
because reporting from Beirut is like
looking at kind of the white light of
truth coming at you
but it's then refracted through a prism
prism of all these factions and thief's
and religious communities so that white
light comes and hits that prism and
suddenly it's splayed out in 15
different directions and that's how it
hits you as a reporter you never get the
truth it's always through that prism and
you get all the those different colors
and you as a reporter have to take a
little of the red band that a little of
the yellow band a little of the blue
band and try to then paint them together
in as close approximation as you can to
that original sort of truth or reality
that's what makes reporting there a
challenge I have another chapter and
reporting from Israel called under the
spotlight which is about why this
country the size of state of Delaware
the population not much larger than
Greater Chicago gets as much news
coverage as the Soviet Union now if
you're over there either and he spent
most your time in Lebanon and in
Jerusalem yeah
how many language did you speak well I
studied both Hebrew as a young man and
Arabic in college I'm not fluent in
either language but um had a enough of a
working knowledge to certainly use both
languages when I needed to to do some
interviews how much english-language
media is available in both those places
well in Beirut you have a lot of
translation services organizations that
would take the Arabic press and Arabic
radio and provide daily transcripts and
readouts in English for the Foreign
Press and the foreign community in
general at times in Beirut there were
also english-language newspapers that
came and went
in Israel you have the daily Jerusalem
Post which is in English and you also
have translation service provided by the
government press office there of the
Arabic press and leading editorials is
it Jerusalem Post the only
english-language newspaper in Israel yes
but no now there's a new one I'm sorry
since I left there's the Jerusalem Post
and another one called the nation
because Wolf Blitzer has been here many
times on the callin chosen him you see
him a lot in this country how powerful
is the Jerusalem Post well within Israel
it's very powerful within the
english-speaking community but you have
to keep in mind that the
english-speaking community is only a
fraction of the Israeli population so as
an Israeli newspaper I'd say its
influence is limited as a newspaper for
world jewelry its influence is extensive
how did they root become the center of
all this activity well part of it is has
to do with the physical location of
Beirut here you had this port city on
the western edge the western frontier of
the Arab world so it had the natural
kind of outlet access first shipping and
later purely even air travel from Europe
it was the first stop as it were the
gateway to the Arab world so to $0.01
Beirut faced West but at the same time
it also faced East looked out on the
Arab world it was an arabic-speaking
country it had an extremely dynamic and
talented Lebanese population that could
and did serve as kind of a bridge kind
of a middleman kind of a non troppo
between the Arab world and the European
world that's why you meet so many
Lebanese who speak English French and
Arabic they and they served as that kind
of bridge so it made them a natural
center point for the Arab world
unfortunately it also made them a stage
or a convenient that playground as it
were for the Arab world to play out a
lot of his conflicts everyone was there
and Beirut everyone had his tentacles
into Beirut and the Syrians could get at
the Iraqis there and the Iraqis could
get at the Jordanians the Jordanians
could get at the Egyptians and everybody
could get at each other you
Beirut because the place was a little
bit loose the rules of the game there
weren't real strict and so it became
kind of the off-broadway for Middle East
conflicts you know if you had the real
conflicts if you Rock and Syria fought
head-to-head as nations that would be
explosive so they played out their fuse
off-broadway and that meant in Beirut go
back to trying to understand I know I
asked this question earlier you go back
to the people the Iraqis the Iranians
and the Lebanese and all the people you
mentioned the Syrians and the Israelis
in a place like Lebanon is the conflict
based again on personal differences or
religious differences among those be we
just mentioned I think it's based on a
tribal competition for space and
resources you know in a tribal
environment nobody really wants to put
himself under the authority of the next
guy because he's afraid in a kind of a
tribal world that the other guy's tribe
is dominant well you know they'll call
all the shots
they'll monopolize all the resources so
I've got to make sure that my tribe then
is dominant and for a brief period of
time the Lebanese were ready to stand
back just a little bit and give just
enough to create kind of a reasonably
strong central government that would in
a way divide the pie neutrally but
eventually that broke down when the
power equation changed and one tribe the
Muslims became demographically much
larger much more powerful than another
tribe the Maronite Christians the
Maronites didn't want to give up their
tribal prerogatives that had been
established when Lebanon was founded
they felt if they put their authority
their lives under the Muslim tribe that
their interests would not be protected
so you had a civil war if if you were in
the American government I know you're
not you may not like this question what
would you do differently than what we're
now in my position as a diplomatic
correspondent for the New York Times
I'll have to up for a diplomatic answer
that I can't really give any advice per
se okay then that's what I do say in the
book maybe this you know is valid and
that at the end of the book Brian I have
a section a chapter on how to be a
statesman in the Middle East and I say
the effective statesman has to learn to
play for different distinct roles he's
got to be able first of all to think
like an obstetrician then he's got to be
able to bargain like a grocer he's got
to be able to behave like a friend and
he's got to know how to fight like a son
of a [ __ ] and the last rapture is how
to be a friendly obstetrician grocer son
of a [ __ ] now let me explain what I
mean when I say first of all he's got to
think like an obstetrician what does
that mean he's got to understand that we
can be the greatest obstetricians for
peace we can be the greatest midwives
for peace in the Middle East
Andrew Kissinger proved that in his day
Jimmy Carter proved that in his day we
can help deliver a settlement but only
if the parties are ready to get pregnant
what I mean by that is only if Arabs and
Israelis are ready to nurture a peace
settlement together and make all the
sacrifices and compromises necessary for
such an agreement only if they're ready
to do that can we be effective players
in the region if they're not ready to do
that then there's nothing we can do we
can't deliver a baby for a barren couple
now these people are famous for saying
to us come on over come on over we want
to get pregnant come shall please come
on over but the truth is often they want
to get pregnant with us the United
States and not with each other and we
have to understand that and know how to
deal with that situation and that's why
I say you've got to think first of all
like an obstetrician and ask yourself is
this couple really ready to get pregnant
really ready to nurture an agreement
together with all the sacrifices and
compromises that would entail are
are they just telling me that in the
waiting room and then going back home
and sleeping in separate bedrooms think
like an obstetrician secondly you got to
be able to play the role of the friend
what does the friend do the friend is
the one first of all who walks you to
school on that first day maybe every day
of the year the friend is the one who
lets you know that there is a world
outside of the tribe that can be trusted
that everything doesn't have to be a
tribal zero-sum conflict where all my
games are all your losses and vice versa
and it's very important to know how to
be the friend because if you want to be
an effective diplomat you want to be
able to bring people along into a peace
settlement you got to be able to put
your arm around them and move them along
sometimes but with your arm around them
the friend also always tells you the
truth about yourself friend never allows
you to delude yourself into thinking
that this problem will go away if I just
close my eyes see you you got to be a
friend
third you got to be able to bargain like
a grocer I have a Lebanese friend who
says in the book you know they're only
two kind of men in the Middle East
there are messiahs and there are
merchants the messiahs come and go with
the political season one season it's
home aney another season it's nasser and
they're like hurricanes they stir up
everything on land but eventually they
move out to sea and when they do they
leave behind what was always there and
that's the grocer this is a merchant
culture and to be an effective statesman
you've got to be able to go into the
closet roll up your sleeves take out
that apron and get into the bazaar and
bargain with these people because that's
what they expect and everyone will be
testing you and whatnot and you have to
know how to be a grocer finally you got
to be a son of a [ __ ] you have to
understand that Middle East diplomacy is
a contact sport okay
that this is a part of the world where
everyone plays by their own rules and
their own rules are no
at all and whatever peace settlement you
achieved there by your efforts as an
obstetrician grocer friend will always
be challenged by people and unless
you're as tough and sob as everybody
else in the region whatever you produce
will easily be blown away your audience
what this book looks like and our guest
is Thomas Friedman Thomas L Friedman who
is currently a reporter chief diplomatic
correspondent for The New York Times
this is a book about the times that he
lived over in the Middle East Beirut to
Jerusalem 1979 to 1988 threat let me
look inside here and get you to tell us
about a couple of things
maybe it's obvious but why did you
decide to dedicate the book to these
people well the book is dedicated to my
late father Harold Friedman and my
mother Margaret Friedman because I
consider this book I guess the most
important achievement in my life and I
wanted to dedicate it to the most
important people in my life my parents
how long has your father been dead since
1973 and then the next page ha ha ha I
thought we'd get to that this tell us
what this is well I think I'd probably
best reading it because I I it's hard to
really describe otherwise it is an
excerpt from The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn which maybe captures in
a nutshell what a lot of this book is
about and and about what in many ways I
found in both Beirut and Jerusalem and
you can indulge me Brian I'll I'll read
it to your readers this is an excerpt as
I said from Mark Twain's The Adventures
of Huckleberry Finn and it is the
opening page of my book did you want to
kill him buck well I bet I did what did
he do to you him he never done nothing
to me well then what did you want to
kill him for why nothing only it's on
account of the feud what's a feud why
where were you raised don't you know
what a feud is never heard of it before
tell me about it well says buck a feud
is this way a man has a quarrel with
another man and he kills him
then that other man's brother kills him
then the other brothers on both sides
goes for one another then the cousins
chip in and by and by everybody's killed
off and there ain't no more feud but
it's kind of slow and takes a long time
has this one been going on long buck
well I should reckon it started 30 years
ago or somewheres along there there was
trouble about something and then a
lawsuit to settle it and then the suit
went again one of the men and so he up
and shot the man who won the suit which
he would naturally do of course anybody
would what was the trouble about buck
land I reckon maybe I don't know well
who done the shooting was it a
Grangerford or a Shepherdson Lord how do
I know it was so long ago don't anybody
know oh yes
panos I reckon and some of the other old
people but they don't know now what the
row was about in the first place when
did you decide to use that as soon as I
read it did you read it um while I was
writing the book then if we continue
opening the book there's something
that's very helpful to somebody like me
when you need historical perspective
what is this and why did you do it it's
a Middle East chronology it's really uh
my own kind of literary road map to the
history of the Middle East I take the
key dates and modern Middle East history
and try to explain in very brief ways
what was important about them and kind
of lay a foundation for the reader in a
very quick and I think easily digestible
way for the prehistory as far as this
book is concerned the history that leads
up to this book when you go out and
speak to groups and you appear on talk
shows and radio shows what are the
questions or the misconceptions that the
American people have about this whole
part of the world that you off you hear
the most well I think the the main
misconception they have about it that is
that it's impossible to understand and
that it's impenetrable and I think the
thing that I try to attack in the book
most of all is that that it is a
comprehensible place that follow certain
rules strange kind of rules but
rulz nevertheless and let me take you by
the hand and come along on this journey
and and I'll explain it to you if I
wanted to go to any of the countries
well let's start with Lebanon and Israel
right now so I want to go how difficult
would it be for me
well Lebanon I think Brian would be
off-limits for you as it is for me the
New York Times won't allow any reporters
to go there because of the threat of
kidnapping which hangs over the place
every day especially for an American
reporters we both are Israel hop on a
plane let me go back to Lebanon go ahead
with the State Department prevent me
from going or would Lebanon prevent me
the State Department would revoke your
passport I believe if you went to
Lebanon your passport is not good for
travel to Lebanon too even if you're a
reporter unless you get a special
exclusion from the stand you do that
yeah the State Department will give that
to you provided you can make a case for
it okay let's let's go to Jerusalem
hop on a plane ll TWA a Pan Am they all
fly there it's a easy way out of New
York fly out of New York yeah and it's
easy as pie you need a visa not if
you're an American not to go to Israel
you do not need it Americans do not need
a visa you get it at the airport all
right we want to go to Damascus I want
to go to Damascus then you got a more
difficult problem and that you'd have to
apply apply for tourist visa through the
Syrian embassy here in Washington and I
don't want to speak for them but I
they're not that easy to acquire but
certainly not impossible if we went
there what kind of conditions would be
fine uh Damascus is a fascinating city
it's got a wonderful old Bazaar a huge
market covered marketplace fantastic
shops would we be accepted oh yeah
Syrians I think I've always found them
welcoming as individuals I'm speaking
here not the government but as
individuals very welcoming and
hospitable people
now you'd fly again straight to Damascus
you'd have to go through Europe there
are no direct flights if once we got to
Damascus let's say we then wanted to go
to Jerusalem
then you got a problem there's certainly
no way to go there directly since the
two countries are technically at war
what you'd have to do would be to drive
to Amman Jordan and then through Jordan
you'd apply for a permit to cross the
Jordan River into Israel and drive from
Amman to Jerusalem
what about Amman Jordan how will we get
to him on from here how do we get to
Amman from here you can fly from New
York to Jordan on Jordanian Airlines do
you have any sense at all of how many
Americans travel to this part of the
world as tourists not the absolute
numbers just that there's a lot going
certainly to Egypt Israel and Jordan all
the time let me ask you about money
because it's a source of a lot of
conversation on this network how many
American dollars are given each year to
this part of the world well we give an
annual grant of roughly three billion
dollars a year in military and economic
aid to Israel and about 2.2 billion
dollars a year and economic aid to Egypt
that's certainly the lion's share of it
and then we give something in the
probably not more than a hundred million
to all the other countries in the area
why do we give money why do we give one
hundred million dollars to Jordan for
instance what we want to support Jordan
which is a pro-american pro-western
country it's been a traditional ally of
the United States and the United States
government has always felt an interest
in seeing that King Hussein a friend of
the United States maintains a stable and
flourishing Kingdom and why the 2.2
billion to Egypt
well the 2.2 billion to Egypt I think
again is because Egypt certainly in the
last decade has become a very
pro-american country and certainly in
the wake of the Camp David peace treaty
has become a real force for peace and
moderation in the region it's a country
that has enormous problems feeding
itself there are a million new Egyptians
born every nine
it is a Malthusian nightmare in terms of
the number of people being born every
day and the limit on resources that the
country lives under and we want to
prevent an explosion there and for 2.2
billion dollars a year it's probably a
small price to pay for that who do who
do we give 100 million dollars to
besides Jordan I don't know that even
the figure with Jordan is 100 million we
have I'm saying that it's probably 100
million total for all the other
countries in the region and are there
other countries besides Jordan Egypt and
I would imagine
Morocco probably gets a little money
Tunisia gets a little money Algeria gets
a little money in addition to the money
do we sell military equipment in
addition to all this Oh Teresa how much
do we sell I couldn't give you absolute
figures right we sell a lot of military
equipment to Saudi Arabia some of the
other Gulf states and certainly to
Israel and Egypt we're talking with
Thomas L Friedman this is what the book
looks like as you can see it's from
Beirut to Jerusalem a book that you
completed on what date I completed it
though there was no one date since
between the editing and the copy editing
and the final proofing but it was
probably finished mark last March how
did you write it physically sitting at a
VDT physically i sat down at my IBM PC
and Jerusalem and when I started the
book and um just started typing do you
write in the morning or the evening I
would basically my scheduled B I'd get
up and read the morning paper have my
breakfast and morning coffee ride my
stationary bicycle and go into my office
close the door and try to write for
about three hours which is about as long
as I could concentrate in a really
productive way and then I would take a
break I'd go for a walk I'd eat lunch
and then I try to write for a couple
more hours in the afternoon and evening
did you rewrite everything that you
wrote once oh yeah everything you you
would read in the book here a
certainly has been written in some case
rewritten and rewritten and rewritten
and what what role does the editor play
in this and and do they really make a
big difference well I think again it
depends on the the writer what role the
editor plays some obviously I came at
the book with a lot of writing
experience I wasn't in any way in office
but at the same time my editor I think
played a very important role in helping
me with organization sometimes you don't
really see the best way to organize the
book as you're writing it and it's very
helpful to have someone say you know the
second half of chapter five would really
make a perfect you know first half of
chapter three and the bottom half of
chapter three should really be the
second half of chapter seven etc etc
it's only you know really sometimes an
outsider that can make those
recommendations for you did you have
days when you just did a block and you
couldn't write it all so definitely or
days that I just didn't have the psychic
energy to be creative I think every
author goes through that you just wake
up in the morning and you say I just
don't feel like writing now and then
other days you just can't stop did you
write from notes or write from the top
of your head both really I wrote from
articles that I had published already I
used to a small extent fresh interviews
and notes I'd taken to a large extent
and then just whatever came out of my
head that was rolling around back there
in the file cabinet what do you expect
to happen beyond the publication of this
book or anything else that comes out of
this book um there's going to be
obviously a paperback edition it was
sold last week it's going to be
published by Ankur Doubleday and there's
also going to be a Dutch Edition a
Hebrew Edition and a British edition of
the book and we expect more foreign
sales in the near future I hate to
mention such a thing on this program but
is there a television or a movie out of
this some people have thought about that
some portions of the book might be an in
make for an interesting show or movie or
whatever but I kind of doubt it but
there are people looking at it
that with that in mind how long have you
been back in Washington I've been here
now in the job right in the job since
January started the day Baker went in
for his confirmation hearings what do
you think of that
compared to this kind of thing well in
many ways I've gone from covering a
street to covering a hall that's really
how I would summarize the transition
from covering the Middle East covering
the State Department and gone from
covering a human drama that was
unfolding before my eyes really to
covering a policy that was invisible or
that is invisible and what is the policy
it's a collection of grunts and nods and
attitudes really you can't say I saw the
policy today it bled all over the
sidewalk I saw the policy today it wept
on my shoulder so as a journalist I
think you're you're much more
constrained in the kind of range of
emotions and and scenes which you're
going to be able to describe I mean
there's only so many ways to say an
administration official said at the same
time what I like about this story and
what I really truly enjoy about it is
that after ten years in the Middle East
you feel I've been to this play before I
know how it ends that the story always
seems to go in circles and the circle is
always downward what I like about my job
now so much is that it's open-ended who
knows where the story of us-soviet
relations is going to end who knows
where the story of Poland is gonna end
who knows where the story of China is
gonna end and what I like about the job
I have now is that it's new it's fresh
and it's open-ended correct me if I'm
wrong but two people that had your job
before have moved on to being involved
some very directly in policy Richard
Burt now is our ambassador the Startalk
system it was actually the national
security correspondent in the Washington
bureau not dumb the diplomat and he also
wanted to be an ambassador Germany right
and Leslie Gelb who who used to have a
similar kind of job personal security
course right it was a military fair the
editor of the page but he did a stint at
the State Department
in the department of political
military-first right is there a
political future for Thomas Frieden
right now I'm just happy as a clam as a
reporter covering the diplomatic beat
and traveling with the Secretary of
State who can who can predict what will
happen down the road but I guess I don't
want to pin you down on whether you're
now has the the ever get a sense that
being on the other side would be
interesting yes definitely I certainly
have had that sense before that at some
point I'd be fascinated to know what it
looks like from the inside I think any
journalist worth his salt wants to know
that too name's Charles Redmond and
Margaret Tong one reason I bring those
two names up and there are others
leaving some out John Hughes I think's
another one
and there are a lot that have pinched
hitted are people that are audience
again see all the time uh-huh you go to
those briefings at this they do or I do
indeed you get anything out of them
definitely definitely
what well in the immediate sense you get
the most immediate declaration of
American policy on any subject you want
to ask for and that's really what
they're important for they're important
for watching the policy involved now you
say wait a minute you know Mari you said
this on Tuesday you're saying this on
Wednesday there's been a shift or an
event happens overseas we want to know
how is our government reacting to the
new situation in Poland you go that the
noon briefing and you find out all right
when you watch and I'm a watcher you you
you watch the assistant secretary come
in and put her write papers down and
open up are there questions yes now as
she's sitting there fully briefed
waiting for you to ask otherwise you'll
never hear from her well or no we can we
can and do talk to Margaret both before
and after the briefing and throughout
the day if something breaks at five
o'clock or seven o'clock I'm on the
phone to her basically she comes in
there with what the various departments
in the State Department think will be
the questions that will ask
so say on a day like today where at the
time we're doing this record in Columbia
now is in the news and the South America
department will sit around early in the
morning and say what might reporters ask
about our policy in Columbia today they
try to anticipate the questions and then
they write guidance for Margaret to use
during the briefing because obviously
she can't personally be up on every area
of the world so she needed guidance from
each department now if we don't ask that
question about Columbia
she will not read that guidance and so
sometimes we miss stories she can
sometimes have very important policy
declarations about a specific subject
which if we don't ask she's not going to
tell he's in a game some extent to some
extent is because we see more of her
right now is she different behind the
scenes and she is in front of that
microphone oh I think I think so I mean
in front of the microphone she's got to
be the stiff super or serious voice of
the State Department and the voice of
the US government to some extent and
that says it should be personally she's
a warm fun extremely enjoyable person
why is it that the State Department has
to be so diplomatic and so careful
because they represent us diplomatically
I think is really you know they really
got to present that kind of most
diplomatic face of the country when you
write a story do you write much from
those briefings or do you find that all
legwork on your own no definitely the
briefings are definitely important we
use material out of them almost every
day you only have a couple minutes left
and again I want our audience to see
this book can you tell us how many books
have been sold well we're in our seventh
printing and over a hundred thousand so
how does everybody here with most books
they're sold well that's a lot of books
for any hardcover book it certainly
obviously as I say a best-seller it's
been number one in the Washington Post
for the last two weeks in August and I
never dreamed I sell a hundred thousand
copies of a serious book on the Middle
East
is it a Book of the Month Club selection
yes it is how did that work well that's
something that's negotiated ahead of
time they read the manuscript they
decide whether they think their audience
the Book of the Month Club subscribers
would find this book of interest and
they give you in advance as well against
their sales and what role does that play
and the bestseller list if the Book of
the Month Club sales are not included in
in the bestseller sales and they haven't
even started yet they won't start till
October well when people rush out and to
buy this book which they can find on
their bookstores and they come back and
sit down and look through the book what
is your absolute favorite chapter in
here that you had the most fun right
my favorite chapter I think that second
one I was telling you about Brian would
you like to eat now or wait for the
ceasefire it was about what it was
really like to live in Beirut and I
think it's both compelling and fun and
if I was any favorite chapter I have in
the book one that I enjoyed most writing
it's that our guest for the last hour
has been Thomas L Friedman and he is
currently the chief diplomatic
correspondent for the New York Times and
this is what his book looks like from
Beirut to Jerusalem thank you sir for
joining us my pleasure thank you